and let's just bring in our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates uh Sam uh
the president of Ukraine there and the
Prime Minister meeting Ukrainian uh
members of the military at that military
base uh endorse it and then appeared
they were both signing a document there
ahead of this press conference uh any
idea what they would have been signing
there
so one of the threads all the way
through today has been the increased
offer of help that the UK has given to
the ukrainians on training uh the Prime
Minister offered to bolster the UK's um
uh help to help Ukraine with expanding
Fighter Jet Pilot training to help
Ukraine defend itself in the skies I
think that's why you saw the British
facilitating a visit to a Dorset
military base I think that's why you saw
president zielinski meeting ukrainians
who are being trained up by the British
army uh because that kind of help is
exactly the kind of thing that
Richardson is going to be expanding and
you saw there both men sit down and sign
a document likely to be a memorandum of
understanding to underpin uh some of the
discussions and agreements that the UK
and Ukraine have made and uh and signed
and sealed today so we are just a few
minutes away from a press conference
what's interesting Sally is that you do
have certain specific offers from the UK
like this increased promise of training
which also includes a promise to begin
immediate training for Marines
but you also have a promise of sanctions
uh at 11 o'clock this morning Britain
sanctioned a number of new companies and
individuals in order to tighten the
Noose around the Russian regime but then
you've got this question of exactly what
is going to happen with fighter jets now
as part of the training promise the UK
has promised in the release from earlier
this morning to offer more training to
Ukrainian fighter pilots to
um to fly fighter jets however when
asked earlier today whether Danny Street
was going to actually send the planes
themselves they were told well it's
going to take quite a while but
potentially up to five years to train
these fighter pilots and there are
better ways that we think that we can
help the Ukrainian so President
zielinski coming to the UK coming to
Westminster to make one big plea which
is her fighter jet it's not quite clear
that the UK is offering specifically
that instead they're offering fighter uh
pilot training uh but it's not quite
clear whether they're going to offer the
Jets and I think that we might hope to
get more clarity from Richie sunac the
prime minister at the press conference
beginning in a few moments uh time as to
whether or not the equipment as well as
the training is on the table uh just how
far he is prepared to go uh Britain like
America like other Western allies uh
very keen to avoid the perception that
we are directly engaging with Russia in
the war in Ukraine but we will find out
more from and president zoletski who are
approaching the peridium now yes thanks
very much let's listen in
good afternoon
Vladimir it's a privilege today and to
have you here in the United Kingdom
path for
a crane to
the past six months with ten thousand of
your soldiers making the journey for
military training and more arriving
every week and just a few days ago
dozens arrived to learn how to operate
our Challenger 2 tanks I'm told they're
already mastering the art of driving the
62-ton sophisticated weapons which will
soon be making a difference on the
battlefield of your country
all over the United Kingdom Ukrainian
men and women are learning how to
command and control NATO standard
weapons whether that is in drone Warfare
tank operations or basic training
their dedication courage and
determination is a credit to you and
your country
and Vladimir your visit here today
underlines our two countries close and
enduring friendship
we will always be by your side your
staunch and unwavering friends
and we both know the people of Ukraine's
Incredible strength and inspiring
bravery will ultimately defeat tyranny
that is why we are training and arming
them with the equipment they need to
push back Russian forces
and as I said to you earlier today we
are also accelerating the delivery of
our equipment the equipment of our
allies to ensure that it reaches your
front line in coming days and weeks not
months or years
the Ukrainian Crews who arrived last
week will be using Challenger 2 tanks to
defend Ukraine's Sovereign territory
next month
and I'm pleased that today we have
agreed that we will expand our training
program a program that has trained 10
000 troops in the last six months alone
to your Marines and fighter jet Pilots
ensuring the Armed Forces of Ukraine are
able to defend their country for
generations to come
we must arm Ukraine in the short term
but we must bolster Ukraine for the long
term your country cannot be left
vulnerable to attack ever again
today we have signed the London
declaration further deepening our
cooperation and in the coming days
we will Mark a year since this needless
and unprovoked Invasion and Russia will
see more than ever
that their tactics
are only solidifying Western resolve
only convincing us to go further and
faster to help you Vladimir and we will
after all you told me last week that
Collective International Unity is your
greatest weapon and you can be sure that
we will deliver on that not just now but
long into the future
thank you so much
um prime minister son of name
um
the Prime Minister the Prime Minister
their journalists dear participants all
the British today together with Mr Prime
Minister we are putting the final
touches on our negotiations and this is
exactly here on this military base where
our Ukrainian awards are undergoing
their training and we began this day
with some defense issues together with
the Rishi and then obviously we also
continue discussing this defense issues
in my address to the British Parliament
and we are closing this day again with
the defense issues we have a very strong
defense package from Great Britain we've
already received some significant number
of armored vehicles and we've agreed to
honor the national uh longer range
missiles and also the training of our
av Ava a voice with regards to
managing the unmanned vehicles and I
believe that together we will cover this
a difficult path to our common factor
and of course today I'm not able to
share with you all of the details what
we've been talking about and how it is
specifically we're going to strength
Ukraine however I would like to say that
this day has become very fruitful and
I'm grateful to a prime minister for
understanding our needs and for his
helpful advice and for the decisions
that are truly helping our Ukrainian
Warriors to become stronger I'm also
grateful to his majesty for the
opportunity to have a meeting and
conversation with him and I'm grateful
to all of the members of the British
Parliament who today during my address
clearly showed that Great Britain will
never betray their Brave Spirit I'm also
grateful to everyone in the United
Kingdom who was today standing with
Ukrainian Flags in London and we saw
that we noticed as we were passing by
and thank you for your support and today
it is very clear that we are standing
together with Great Britain together
with the Prime Minister we signed
declaration of unity a document that
truly records principles of our
interaction and mutual support and this
is truly a different a new level of our
relations we also emphasized
the achieved level of support whether
it's insecurities sanctions political
and economical cooperation something
that truly strengthened things are both
countries we've also discussed caused
our position on the international
platform my deep gratitude to visit in
all of Great Britain for you
Readiness and willingness to work with
us in executing the Ukrainian peace
formula and I also would like to thank
all of our Ukrainian Warriors but it's
every Soldier Sergeant officer or
general our state is doing and will be
doing to make sure that on the front
lines
everything in the maximum maximum that's
owned by other
leading countries Ukraine will be among
those countries who has everything to
defend their people glory to everyone
fighting for Ukraine many thanks to
everyone who helps Ukraine again thank
you I wish you thank you to all the
people in great fitting thank you thank
you for all this 350 days of unity glory
to Ukraine thank you so much thank you
Vladimir thank you for the kind words I
think we have some time for a few
questions from the media can we start
with ITV News
there's someone here
hello
I'm Mr President first of all
brawled into
further support but I think a lot of
British people want to know some of the
specifics for example when do you
believe this Russian offensive will
happen how many fighter jets do you need
when do you need them
and what happens if you don't get them
and to you Mr Prime Minister you seem to
be inching towards a position of being
able to provide fighter jets to once for
the ukrainians can you offer absolute
Clarity here and now will they get them
and if so when
thanks uh Rohit for the question what a
nice start and then uh I'll do that look
first of all we've been very clear and
we've been clear for a long time that
when it comes to the provision of
military assistance to Ukraine nothing
is off the table and that's because
we're determined to ensure that Vladimir
the president and his people can be
victorious against Russian aggression
and we've backed up that rhetoric with
action last year behind the United
States we were the single largest donor
of military equipment to Ukraine and we
said that we would match or exceed that
amount almost two and a half billion
pounds again this year and you saw when
it came to the provision of main battle
tanks we were the first G7 Nation I
announced that weeks ago something that
President and I had discussed previously
it was important in order to ensure that
Ukraine can make progress on the
battlefield
and I think we helped lead an
international conversation which led to
many other countries following us and
providing main battle tanks to Ukraine
so when it comes to a fighter combat
aircraft of course they are part of the
conversation indeed we've been
discussing that today and have been
previously and that's why we've
announced today that we will be training
Ukrainian Air Force on NATO standard
platforms because the first step in
being able to provide Advanced aircraft
is to have soldiers or aviators that are
capable of using them that is a process
it takes some time we've started that
process today that's because we're keen
to support the president and his country
in delivering a victory and nothing is
off the table and our leadership on this
issue is something that we all
collectively should be very proud of and
I know that the president is grateful
for
thank you thank you very much thank you
for your question with regards to the
equipment with the equipment that we
need of course there's a lot of
equipment we need and a lot of different
equipment it all depends on the
situation depends on the situation on
the battlefield on the day kind of in
the military Direction but also depends
on what's happening within the country
you know how we are fighting against the
Iranian drones you know there are
hundreds and thousands of them and
um and we're fighting against them by
various means and that includes also
ballistic missiles because this unmanned
because this Iranian drones they hit
civilians infrastructure educational
infrastructure hospitals schools
civilians you know because they are
trying to threaten ukrainians but
they're trying to make them flee but
ukrainians are not going to Lee because
that is why when we talk about this we
do need ear defense systems and we are
grateful to everyone who is providing
them and that also
um
when we have those systems that allows
people to go to work and work and every
and once we once people work obviously
this money they'll not just go to for
pensions or other social welfare but
also this also goes to support our
Warriors that's why it's very important
that we have everything needed to
support people in their jobs and when we
talk about the battlefield what are our
priorities of course armored vehicles
you know we know that our enemy has got
thousands units of armored vehicles you
know back from the uh back from the
Soviet Union Heritage and of course NATO
armored vehicles they are the best and
yet there are only few of them you know
when you only have 10 NATO armored
vehicles against a thousand of Soviet
armored vehicles well what are the
chances you know
and we have no way out we have to stand
firm we need armored vehicles we need
tanks we need flyer Jets and obviously
we've spent a lot of time talking about
this together and you've just heard what
uh Mr Prime Minister mentioned today and
tomorrow we will be meeting with the EU
leaders and discussing this issues and
also a longer range missiles that's our
priority and I'm very grateful that
Britain has finally heard us in that
regard and I do hope that other
countries will also hear us when it
comes to a longer range missiles you
know because we do need to push back the
Russians so people can just live
to the offensive you know what what can
I say frankly we live in the state of
War what can I say here we cannot be
just thinking about offensive defense
has never happened you know it's just
been a different kind of intensity
so all we need to think is that let us
make Russians think about Ukrainian
counter offensive okay they need to be
thinking about this they need to be
thinking how they should be living our
territory that's all I would like to
share with you thank you thank you
Vladimir next can't call on BBC Ukraine
you know
security understandable
my question is do you Mr sunat I uh you
know that Ukrainian soldiers they are
dying every day don't you think that
that decision about workplace is taking
too long and uh yeah and the other
question is what are your steps to clear
the reputation of London as a city that
is still laundering Russian money
so with I think you heard from the
president's previous answer Natalia
about the very immediate needs and
that's air defense and long-range
missiles and that's the conversation
that we've been having most recently
about how can we provide air defense to
protect the Ukrainian population that
has been the thing that we've talked
about probably most in all of our
conversations which is why we've
provided
thousands of surface-to-air missiles and
air defense systems and will continue to
do so and more are coming over the next
few weeks and as the president said
probably the most crucial capability
right here and now is main battle tanks
which we LED on but also those
long-range missiles uh that I think that
and all the the talking that we've done
and the planning for how we can have
decisive Victory on the battlefield and
make progress it requires long-range
missiles which currently the range is
not there and again that's the
conversation that we've been having and
again we hope that Britain can lead but
when it comes to protecting soldiers I
think we we we feel very acutely the
tragedy and the hardship that your
country and your country men are going
through and I you know we've both had
the privilege of meeting some of them
today I've met some of them in the past
and their bravery is inspiring it's
awe-inspiring to see as I have you know
the ordinary citizens young young men
and women who are fighting to defend
their country free and being trained to
do so here and they go with not just our
wishes and our training but they go with
our full support with all the equipment
that we can continue to provide them and
we'll continue to do so but rest assured
we are here with you with your people
and continue to provide you with
whatever we can to ensure their safety
and indeed their success
thank you and with regard to sanctions I
think we've as you as you saw at the
beginning of this conflict I used to be
the Finance Minister and we put in place
the president talked about it earlier
today probably the most extensive and
forward-leaning sanctions package of any
country at the beginning of this
conflict to demonstrate very clearly
that Russia's aggression was
unacceptable and we would punish them in
every which way we could we've announced
further sanctions today but continually
when it comes to sanctions uh we have I
think LED and you remember the
conversations we had on on things like
Swift and Banks right at the beginning
of this conflict again it was Britain
that led the way in pushing for very
strict sanctions and and as we've
announced further today and wherever we
can continue you know to tighten them
and do more we will look to do so as we
have done today
uh next uh can we go to Sky News please
thank you Dominic wagorn Sky News prime
minister if I could ask you first of all
it does seem to have been a a lag
between Ukraine asking for more
sophisticated weaponry and it eventually
being given they are some more advanced
artillery it was eventually sent they've
asked for tanks and they will be sent
eventually they now want fighter jets
and we're training their pilots but
we're not sending the Jets your
predecessor one of your predecessors a
close friend of President zelensky who's
has wondered why we're not doing more
why not send more so they can finish off
the job now what is holding the west
back why is there that lag Mr President
good to see you again if I could ask you
about fighter jets how urgently do you
need them and what does it mean for your
country if you don't get them
so I mean I'll I'll take that that's the
first question and again I'd probably
slightly written the the the notion of
the question because I think we have
continually LED actually in the UK with
a provision of equipment to Ukraine and
whether it was right at the beginning
with anti-tank missiles whether as you
heard from the president the importance
of armored vehicles I think we've sent
hundreds uh whether it's artillery guns
again in the next few weeks a new set of
batteries of our artillery guns will
arrive at tanks we've already talked
about and we're training combat aircraft
for the first time indeed actually
something that we should have probably
been doing a long time ago because we
have a long-standing training
relationship with Ukraine that predates
the war but that is something as we look
forward we'll want to continue to do
more of as we want to make sure that the
Ukrainian armed forces are trained on
NATO standard equipment and there's
greater interoperability between Ukraine
and NATO which is very much something
that we've been discussing so I think
actually we've continued to be on the
forward Leading Edge of it and we're
providing things as quickly as we can
that the the the Challenger tanks are
going to be on the battlefield as I said
in a matter of weeks I mean you've seen
the Ukrainian soldiers being trained on
them as fast as we can and we're
providing them as fast as we can and we
know that they will they will make a
difference and I think the president
would tell you you know we've been
having conversations for the few months
that I've had this job and relatively
rapidly after we discuss what is
necessary in the Ukraine sees that we do
respond and then we Galvanize others to
respond to that's what we have done and
that's what we'll continue to do
foreign
I would like to be honest with you here
in the history of this war there are
several pages and one of these pages so
in fact even uh sections it may be in
this war it's been a very special
section uh for um
for our worries and also Great Britain
providing equipment and here we're
talking about driven lines as well and
then our people had to rise up and they
had to fight with what they had you know
we're not we're not doing any
self-peating here okay what they had
they were doing and we were just
grateful to for whatever we were getting
and then we turned another page you know
and then we turned into we're we all
turned into fury because
Russians were just killing and murdering
people and they were raping people and
we were ready to have anything in use
any kind of weapons just to destroy them
and then we turned another page
artillery you know we needed artillery
we needed to work in a different
direction and this is exactly where we
received as some help and support
for example
in certain places obviously Great
Britain helped us a lot but when it
comes to high Mars we've got a lot of
help from the us and we are really
grateful to them for this page in the
history of War
I think it's very important to
understand that Russia has no pity for
their own people they just keep on
throwing their people in to the
battlefield you know we have pity and we
protect our people we would not throw
them just onto the battlefield we needed
to prepare them
and that that kind of marked a different
stage in the world and now we've come to
kind of this stagnation phase you've
just asked me what would happen if you
don't get this fighter jets or longer
range missiles or we don't have enough
ammunition or because everything
obviously is you know running out and
coming out of maintenance
if you don't have the 1085 artillery you
know there will be stagnation these
people will be coming and be living on
our territory and this will pose great
risk to all of the world because they've
just now they've captured a nuclear
station and they just live there you
know
and this kind of risk will be everywhere
because there are terrorists
and so without the weapons that we are
discussing now and the weapons that we
just discussed with a Rishi here today
and how Britain is going to help us you
know all of this is very important
without this there will be stagnation
which will not bring to anything good
thank you next we have inter
good evening Mr Prime Minister of
president president
okay so you've already summarized
your day today and yet I am very
interested in your personal Impressions
you know obviously
you've hardly spent even a handful of
days outside of Ukraine you know in a
different country just under the
peaceful sky so what are your personal
impressions
and what threatens me back at home
you know yes this is my second visit
outside of Ukraine after the beginning
of the Russian invasion and you know
what I had to do two important things
and first of all I had to express our
deep gratitude the credit of all the
Ukrainian people to the people of Great
Britain to the government of Great
Britain to everyone who had been helping
us to keep our land to make sure that we
don't lose it because this is our land
which is dear to us I think it's amazing
that Great Britain has been so active in
this fight
and yeah I am grateful uh we should we
should not be forgetting everything when
we've gone through all of this month at
any point we could have lost our
independence and yes
all of that time you haven't had
battalions unfortunately battalions or
friends and allies but yet we had a very
strong unit of friends Partners allies
and Great Britain has has
Ally and friend here and
I also would like to say that whatever
you can do you know we should be doing
and this is what I'm we are trying to do
we are trying to remember who has been
with us from the very first day of the
war you know because we will get this
picture but it just doesn't happen
overnight
and uh you know our Warriors our
partners of people those are the key
kind of the key
how would I put it probably you know
key aspects that helped us to be strong
and to push back the enemy yet the war
has not ended
scar to it and then there is another
reason why why I'm here with this visit
and that's the um a heavy artillery and
that's why I'm here you know I'm here
again we have to do what we can do we
have to come and we talk we have to talk
openly we have to be frank
the president of the country which is
fighting now for the independence and
that's why I have to do everything
possible to make sure that our partners
give everything they can to strengthen
us on the battlefield so those are just
two reasons you know gratitude and
weapons although yes London is a very
beautiful city it's a shame I don't have
time for this
thank you a little bit right and lastly
Harry uh the Sun
are you uh prime minister
um you say that Britain led the world
rightly on training Ukrainian troops
um on providing arms and you yourself on
tanks but there does seem to be a
reticent to break ranks with the Western
allies on jets are you personally
willing as prime minister if you can to
send Ukraine some of our typhoon Fleet
and Mr President on behalf of billions
of sun readers I just like to say
welcome and Slava Ukraine Boris Johnson
says there's no conceivable reason for
Britain and the West not to send you
Jets what are the reasons that they're
telling you privately and are those
reasons credible thank you very much
Beth thanks I so I think you're totally
wrong to say that there's been any
reticence
and actually we we were the first G7
country to provide main battle tanks we
were also the first country to provide
serious arms to Ukraine at the beginning
and we we have genuinely LED other
countries and that's something we should
all be very proud of and when it comes
to the Quantum of our support Second
only to the United States last year and
again a commitment to provide the same
or more this year uh and then there's
also as well as the the things that we
provide there's also the and I think the
president would attest to this the very
close cooperation and engagement between
our teams as to how that Ukraine can be
successful with all the support and
training as you're seeing here but also
the help that we provide across the
board so I don't think there's been any
reticence at all actually and we've
probably been the most forward-leaning
country and trying to bring about a
Ukrainian victory in this conflict and
that's why as prime minister we decided
to change our strategy to accelerate and
intensify the amount support that we
give Ukraine so that we can bring about
more decisive victory in a sooner period
of time and that's why we I made the
decision to provide tax and with regret
with regard to aircraft as I said we've
already said nothing is off the table
and the first step on that has to be to
have a people who can fly what are very
sophisticated pieces of Kit I mean from
start if you take someone who's brand
new for a fighter jet as as flooding
would also say it takes three years and
obviously that's not what we're working
with because Ukraine has existing
fighter pilots but we do need to make
sure that they can operate the aircraft
that they could potentially be using but
also there's a supply chain around such
sophisticated aircraft those are the
conversations that the president and I
are having are making sure that we
understand all the supply chain needs
that go along alongside aircraft like
that making sure that they can be used
and used safely and kept safely so we're
having that conversation and it's also a
conversation we are having with our
allies because particularly some of the
aircraft that we have are are done
through joint treaty with multiple other
countries and I think we've seen that
with previous bits of kit that have
others have had to give for aircraft
that is something that we are we are
also involved in because we have as I
said there are other allies involved in
the provision of those bits of equipment
and as the president said he's on his
way to Europe after this to pick up this
conversation with our partners and
allies over there but where we can
throughout this conflict we have been
nothing but out in front and proud
proudly so and I know the difference
that it's making and I'm I know the
president is grateful for it and that's
what we will continue to do
foreign
truly truly I am grateful and again even
today once again I heard from Mr Prime
Minister the desire to provide fighter
jets and officially he declared that we
they can begin training our Pilots
again not also when it comes to typhoons
not everything depends just on the
decision of Great Britain
and I will be working in that direction
because again this is how we are
changing and how we have been able to
change many things we are intensifying
our diplomacy and I do believe just
within a day we will be able to meet
with a dozen of EU leaders and then
we'll go back home because this is
obviously very important
obvious say all of this conversations
they have to be taking place quickly and
again when it comes to Typhoon you know
I didn't even I didn't even know that it
takes three years to train a pilot like
that you know come on we will be sending
you Pilots who've already trained for
two and a half years you know
people accelerate the last bit yeah
thank you and I think on that point
another example of it is the
conversation we're having on long range
missiles where again the conversation
that we're having is one that is I think
out in front of other allies about
making sure Ukraine has the longer range
capabilities that it needs at this phase
of the battle and that's a very
productive conversation that that we're
having today as well
good fantastic well thank you very much
for your questions
and that was president zielinski and
prime minister Rishi sunak uh speaking
there at a military base in Dorset
taking questions uh from attending
journalists but certainly no major
announcements certainly uh in terms of
President zielinski's request for
fighter jets president zielinski very
much Towing the line in terms of being
grateful for what the UK has offered so
far and Rishi soon act certainly just
repeating that the UK will be training
Ukrainian Pilots but absolutely no
pledge yet of giving Ukraine those fast
jets that they are asking for that said
the defense secretary is investigating
what possibilities could lie in terms of
offering air support
to Ukraine and we can bring in our
Deputy political editors Sam Coates who
is in Westminster and has been listening
into that press conference as well Sam
no major announcement but what were your
takeaways from what we heard there
well to be honest Ellie once again yet
again with another Rishi sunak media
event you came away ever so slightly
frustrated by the whole thing because uh
clearly this is an important day clearly
this is a day where UK Ukrainian
relationships have been underpinned by
an important set of diplomacy and
ceremony
everybody forgot what happened or the
people on stage forgot what happened
just four hours ago in Westminster Hall
when the Ukrainian president flew from
Kiev in order to make one demand and
that demand was very clear he said we
want combat aircraft for Ukraine wings
for freedom and he made that cry just
after presenting the Speaker of the
House of Commons with a fighter jet
helmet to symbolize the importance of
the single wish that he is uh asking for
from the UK and from Western Nations and
therefore Rishi sunak when asked
repeatedly by journalists whether it was
Sky's Dominic wagorn or the sons Harry
Cole or uh the BBC Ukrainian uh reporter
who was there what about these fighter
jets
um looked almost sort of slightly hurt
and injured that the suggestion that
Britain wasn't doing enough but but this
was the question set by the Ukrainian
prime minister and and to be honest
Sally there wasn't a clear answer to it
what the Prime Minister was saying
essentially was Britain has done a lot
already and that it takes a lot to train
fighter pilots and that uh Eden although
nothing is off the table there are a
whole range of issues whether they're
supply line issues whether they're
issues about planes that are controlled
uh jointly with other countries uh
whether or not it's the time it takes to
train up a fighter pilot all of those
things Richardson like eventually uh in
answer to the final question from the
Sun seem to suggest were the reasons why
he couldn't just say yes they're on
their way and he he appeared so he sort
of put out that people kept asking this
single question time and time again
through the different moments in that in
that press conference I I thought you
got the sort of clearest insight to
what's going on from president zielinski
who at the end said look it's not just
up to the UK to do this there are other
countries that need to take decisions as
well and I think I think what we're
seeing here is a slightly diplomatically
frustrating experience for the Prime
Minister who is probably trying to move
at the same step as at the same speed as
other European and Western allies when
it comes to promising the supply of
different uh types of Weaponry at the
moment that discussion is all around
fighter jets but can't go further
perhaps that even he would he would like
but feeling that he should be getting
more credit that he's getting for doing
uh what Britain has done a little swipe
I thought at the end from president
zelensky originally said look it takes
two or three years to trade a fighter
pilot we've got to make sure uh that uh
that that you have people that can fly
these things because they're incredibly
complicated president's electricity
turned around and looked at him and said
well you say it says take takes two
years of training we'll Supply you with
somebody who's had two and a half years
of training uh and there was a sort of
awkward uh moment at the end where she
said well well we'll try and do the last
bit as quickly as possible I I think
that underlines the frustration on the
Ukrainian side with uh the Western
Alliance uh not doing what the singular
request of Ukraine is at the moment no
doubt that president zelinsky was very
grateful for the support that Britain
gives generally but on the one specific
that he flew one and a half thousand
miles to London to Westminster Hall to
ask MPS for there was just still uh a no
note of certainty from the Prime
Minister desperate otherwise to try and
get political capital from his
relationship with the Ukrainian
president and as you outline there uh
Sam it is a complex bit of Kit to offer
Ukraine not least because of the
training time but also the spare parts
the servicing of those aircraft which in
the UK would be done by someone who's
highly qualified and highly paid of
course the concern would be who would
take care of of those roles if they were
to give Fast Jets to Ukraine and the
caution among Western allies has been
this concern over escalation uh what do
you make of the timing of this visit
from president zielinski here ahead of
visiting the EU you tomorrow do you
anticipate that it could be more talk of
fast yet it's there too
I think this question is going to
dominate the next few days which of
course comes in the lead up to the first
anniversary of the Russian invasion of
Ukraine I think that President zelinski
needs to keep the momentum going ahead
of that anniversary to make sure the
West's Focus doesn't drop I think that
we're very conscious that a lot of the
coverage a lot of the global attention
is on turkey and Syria after that
horrific earthquake but I think that uh
you know president zielinski is going to
now go around European capitals making
the case that he's made in London uh I I
wonder whether the kind of line from
Rishi tsunaco look it's all very
complicated much more complicated than
people realize particularly goes down
well one one one sort of tonal tick that
Rishi sunak uh has when talking uh about
um uh about this Affairs he kept saying
what the president thought while the
president was standing next to him it
was a bit weird you've got to understand
the president would tell you just how
grateful he was he kept saying as
zelinski was standing alongside him
sometimes the Management Consultant
speak creep to the four which is that
saying we've probably been the most
forward-leaning country in bringing
about Russia's defeat
um I think that what sometimes is uh
expected from the public in situations
like this is kind of broad broad uh sort
of passion and and inconveniently for
Rishi sunak that's what's brought to the
debate by Boris Johnson who issued a
statement earlier today and has been
hovering in the background of this
debate but the truth is this is a
question not just for the UK but it is a
question for other European leaders and
the Americans and that's why president
uh zelenski will likely travel on to
other European capitals after he leaves
the UK this evening okay Sam we really
appreciate your analysis thanks very
much
and our International Affairs editor
Dominic waghorn was at that news
conference and joins us live now uh
hello good to see you uh Dominic of
course you you asked a question uh to
both the Prime Minister and president
zielinski there and as I was just
discussing with Sam Coates offering fast
Jets is is a highly complex bit of kit
uh to give to Ukraine what was your
takeaway from uh the question that you
asked which was put simply why not give
them everything they need now to finish
the job
yeah but I was put in the Boris Johnson
question really which is uh as he has
said uh why not give the ukrainians
everything they need to to finish things
off now and saying to the Prime Minister
there is this sense of a lag between the
ukrainians demanding or requesting more
sophisticated weaponry and eventually
the West being prepared to hand that
over in a sense it's a slightly unfair
question as Sam was saying that you know
it is difficult for the Prime Minister
because the British do feel that they
have kind of been forcing the pace
themselves they have been a leader in
the lead handling over enlaw anti-tank
missiles early on and they really broke
the Log Jam over tanks by agreeing to
send Challenger tanks that then kind of
push the Germans and the Americans into
sending battle tanks as well but there
is that sense that not just Britain but
also amongst the other allies there is a
kind of reticence to give the ukrainians
what they need and that's the reason why
or one of the reasons why arguably this
conflict is dragging on we're now into a
almost a year and the Ukrainian
president was saying that if he doesn't
get the kind of weapons he's asking for
there's going to be stagnation which for
his country means many more deaths and
this going on and on and on and while
that goes on there's always the risk of
War leading to misunderstanding to
miscalculations and a much wider even
more worrying conflict that's why I
thought it's necessary to ask the Prime
Minister why there is that lag why does
that perceived lag between the
ukrainians saying what they need and the
West being prepared to give them I think
you know listen to the way he slightly
bristles at the question not just
because I was referring to Boris Johnson
but because I did I do think he feels
that Britain is leading the way but also
I had to press president zielinski on
the issue of fighter jets because he has
been dropping a lot of not very subtle
hints today about the need for fighter
jets but he didn't really clearly answer
the question earlier when he's asked
what it would mean for his country if he
doesn't get them have a listen
I think actually we've continued to be
on the forward Leading Edge of it and
we're providing things as quickly as we
can that the the the Challenger tanks
are going to be on the battlefield
soldiers are being trained on them as
fast as we can and we're providing them
as fast as we can and we know that they
will they will make a difference and I
think the president would tell you you
know we've been having conversations for
the few months that I've had this job
and relatively rapidly after we discuss
what is necessary either Ukraine sees
that we do respond and then we Galvanize
others to respond to that's what we have
done and that's what we'll continue to
do
I think it's very important to
understand that Russia has no pity for
their own people they just keep on
throwing their people in to the
battlefield you know worse we have pity
and we protect our people we would not
throw them just onto the battlefield we
needed to prepare them
and that that kind of marked a different
stage in the world and now we've come to
kind of this stagnation phase
I think it's important to put this into
context as well because six months ago
or so the idea of the British prime
minister talking about sending Advanced
long-range missiles to Ukraine or tanks
even and particularly talking about the
possibility even of sending fighter jets
saying that's all on the table I think
would have been a lot more remote than
it is now it shows how far we have come
that's partly because of the kind of
remorseless Logic the military logic of
the kind of mission creep if you send
battle tanks uh to a country like
Ukraine military experts say that they
those tanks to work properly to to not
be vulnerable will need air cover
Ukraine doesn't really have the right
kind of air cover not insufficient
Advanced capabilities at least yeah and
therefore there's a kind of logic to the
ukrainians saying they need to have
fighter jets now that will take time for
them to get but there is a real logic
behind them asking for for that I think
some people will see that as an
encouraging sign that it is going to get
eventually what it needs to see off this
Russian threat others will wonder where
we're going is this a spiral towards
eventually Western troops ending up in
Ukraine and it's becoming a much deeper
conflict all I can say from this point
is that we are getting more and more
involved in sending more advanced
Weaponry to the ukrainians weapons that
they say they vitally need because they
believe a much bigger Russian
counter-offensive is imminent possibly
in the coming weeks
absolutely we appreciate your analysis
Dominic wagorn thank you